okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest on the channel
jess say hi hi
um so you guys probably recognize her
she has been on the show the pregame
that i have on my channel which is a
live show three nights a week um so as i
said i have a special announcement this
week and that is that jess is gonna be
doing a new series on my channel
where we show her red pill content and
you guys are gonna slowly like watch her
get red pilled
should be fun
so what do you know about the red pill i
i literally know nothing about the red
pill i've seen um
a few things here and there but i never
knew it was called red pill until you
told me like oh it's called red phil i'm
like
oh okay okay have you heard of kevin
samuels i have heard of kevin samuel
[Music]
what do you think of him
there's some times where he has
valid points i'm like okay that makes
sense other times i feel like
he's just
talking out the side of his mouth and
i'm like you sure
so
there can be times when he's like very
intense and i'm like
that's a little harsh
but um
other than that i don't watch him a lot
they call him the godfather
of the manosphere one of them have you
heard of rolo tomasi no
no okay no i feel like i've seen like
these people but i just never
watched him
so today i'm showing her jordan peterson
so
that um have you
i'm gonna show you his face
jordan have you seen this guy on the
left before no i have not okay so just
to give you some context
jordan peterson is a psych
um a psychologist okay and so he's been
like studying like gender differences
for years okay and
this is kathy newman and she's like a
hardcore feminist
okay so um
i am going to say as little as possible
i want you to like tell me your thoughts
as you watch this all right okay
let me put a quote to you from the book
where you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim that western
culture in particular is an oppressive
structure created by white men to
dominate and exclude women
well then i want to put minorities to
dominate okay sure but i want to put you
that here in the uk for example let's
take that as an example the gender pay
gap stands at just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women running
the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but
multivariate analysis of the pay gap
indicate that it doesn't exist
but that's just not true is it i mean
that's nine percent kept pay gap that's
a gap between median hourly earnings
between men and women
but there's multiple reasons for that
one of them is gender but it's not the
only reason like if you're a social
scientist worth worth your salt you
never do a univariate analysis
like you say well women
in aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a fact
okay what do you think so far
i don't understand the point that she's
trying to make because i'm like
you she said what he said in his book
what he quoted in his book
and he was like yeah and then she said
about the work for it then she was like
he was like yeah it's like
i'm trying to understand what it is what
the point she's trying to make because
she essentially
just said like
okay this is what it says in your book
and this is what has happened in real
life
so both of them are true and
i i agree with it but um not but but
anyways
the way he's i like the way he's
talking in this little bit that i've
heard him talk because it seems like
it's very
knowledgeable and he's not just like
running off the mouth i know there's
like still 15 minutes left but
um
i think what it
has been said so far is true like there
is
there is a huge like difference in um
and just like pay gap there's a pay gap
for men and women and
universities as well how just like it's
been geared around a certain demographic
like from jump and
there hasn't i won't say there hasn't
but there hasn't been a lot of
things to implement like change to where
it
it's for
everybody
really so that's what you gathered so
far yeah okay we'll continue
to get to the top no i'm not saying it
doesn't matter either you're saying
there are multiple reasons for it yeah
but those reasons why why should women
put up with those reasons
why should women be content i'm not
saying that they should have put up with
it i'm saying that the claim that the
wage gap between men and women is only
due to sex is wrong and it is wrong
there's no doubt about that the
multivariate analysis have been done
so i can give you
multi-varied analysis
i'm saying that 9 pay gap exists that's
a gap between men and women i'm not
saying why it exists but it exists now
if you're a woman that seems pretty
unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid 9 less than a man that's
not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening i can
give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
just less agreeable people for the same
job
women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization
or agreeableness that's true but that's
right and some women get paid more than
men so you were saying that by and large
women are too agreeable to get the pay
rises now i'm saying that that's one
component of a multivariate equation
that predicts
um salary
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so
surely you need about another 20 we
needed about another 18 factors one of
which is gender and there is prejudice
there's no doubt about that but it
accounts for a much smaller proportion
of the variance in the pay gap than the
radical feminists claim okay so rather
than denying the pay gap exists which is
what you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay right make yourself disagreeable
with your book oh definitely there's
that but i also didn't deny it existed i
denied it existed because of gender okay
okay that was a different vibe
so
for me i'm the type of person i like to
learn if there's like an area where i am
ignorant and i'm not gonna just be like
oh no like
women should be paid more doesn't matter
blah blah blah but from what he is
saying from a psychological standpoint i
can understand that and he's not
generalizing
all women
but i understand that some women can be
more agreeable and sometimes you don't
want someone that's gonna if you need a
big deal done you're not gonna want
somebody that's agreeable you're gonna
want somebody that's like a little
go-getter
but
it's
it's hard when like those factors aren't
talked about and it's just like people
you know gender gender gender gender
gender
but there
is other factors that play into that
my question if i was to ask him i would
be i would ask him like well what
happens or what
why if there's women that
aren't as agreeable or just have like
those same characteristic
characteristics as a male why aren't
they
looked at as like okay
if i hired this man or if i hired this
woman they would be able to get the same
job done and i could pay them the same
so i'm so excited for you to watch the
rest guys this is so fun oh i love
showing people though
very very very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i'm mean the pay gap between men and
women exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises one
of the reasons okay one of the reasons
so why not get them to ask for a pay
rise
many many times in my career and they
just counsel oh they do it all the time
you can it's so one of the things that
you do as a clinical psychologist is um
assertiveness training so you might say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression
and you and maybe the next most common
category after that would be
assertiveness training and so i've had
many many women extraordinarily
competent women in my clinical
consulting practice and we put together
strategies for their career development
that involve continual pushing competing
for higher wages and often tripled their
wages within a five-year period
you celebrate
of course so
do you actually
go ahead
she
this lady she's so annoying
she's hiding getting on my nerves like
you celebrate that isn't that what
is that what you're talking about like
it's like lady what have you done
i know nothing about this lady but it's
like
she's the way she's interviewing him
is
as if she's trying to like put words in
his mouth and make him say like
this is the reason why women get paid
less because they're a female and they
can't do anything about it it's just
like
i understand it's a debate and she has
her views and he has his views just like
let him talk learn something learn
something you know what's funny he went
on there to talk about his book
and then
i didn't even tell him what is the what
is the title of his book or what is it
12 rules for life it's a self-help book
okay
i read it it's decent like it's pretty
good it sounds like a good book and like
talking about this okay
and then he's just like interrogated by
this woman oh do you know how he got
famous no so he there was a law in
canada
is he from canada yeah he's canadian
okay so he there was a law in canada
where they said he had to use gender
pronouns
and he said he wouldn't do it but it
wasn't because he wasn't for like trans
people is because he believes in freedom
of speech yeah so he said i'm not going
to do that because the government is
requiring me to and that's like
unconstitutional basically but yeah
everyone hated him so that's kind of
like why she's like coming at him like
this is because like he kind of became
like an anti-trans like like that's how
they would paint him out to be even
though he said multiple times like he
would call someone that if they asked
him to but like i'm not going to do it
and be required by law yeah
that's
that's crazy so in like his writing they
wanted him to use like they them
pronouns oh i didn't put this piece of
context he's a professor
okay so at a university okay
they said like legally the teachers have
to
call the students by their preferred
pronouns and he said no because you
cannot
require me to do that you cannot tell me
what words i can or cannot say yeah if
like i can understand if a student is
like hey like call me like uh she her or
he him like okay understandable but if
they don't come up and tell you
i'm gonna call you what you look like
and if you look like what i think you
look like until you correct me i'm going
to keep calling you that yeah well he he
said it wasn't about the trans people it
was about the law yeah yeah that's a
government overreach yeah
what
i never thought about is what is the
constitution in canada i don't i don't
know but i think he studied tyranny okay
and that's like one of the ways like
governments become tyrannical is by
requiring speech so it's like the
beginning of you know what i'm saying
like it's like that's how they start
they say it's the pronouns then it's you
can't say this you can't say it and then
it like keeps going and that's why like
freedom of speech is so important yeah
like
okay we're gonna next next one do you
agree that you would be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured and you're saying the cost of
men that's a problem oh there's all
sorts of things that it could be at the
cost of it could even be at the cost of
women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing today like having
children
well or choosing careers that actually
happen to be paid less which women do a
lot of but why shouldn't women have the
right to choose not to have children or
the right to choose those demanding they
do they can
yeah that's fine but you're saying that
makes them unhappy by and large i'm
saying that that no i'm not saying that
i'm i and i actually haven't said that
so just saying it makes them miserable
oh my days all my days
this lady
is
and i don't want to like keep pausing it
because she's just
like the stuff that she's saying he he
never said he's like shouldn't women
have the choice that we we do like
what we do
it's just
the thing is like when we do have
children i don't know how it is i think
here is more like hey if you have a if
you have a child here we're going to
help you out through it in the states
it's like oh if you have a child
have fun
and go raise that child we ain't going
to pay you so
i
i just don't understand what her
her point is i can see like
that
i wish that was something that was more
um
helpful right yeah helpful for women to
be able to say like okay i want to have
a child and i can i know that my work is
going to stand behind me in this instead
of being felt like they're left out on a
limb in some companies when they do have
a
child keep going
just keep breathing and keep breathing
no i said that what was making them
miserable was having part was having
weak partners
that makes them miserable right um i
would say that many women around the age
of i would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and i think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to
get the major pieces of their life put
together faster than men which is also
part
i can't hear you
my life's not together yet
and i'm right there knocking on 28.
don't i don't want to hear it no
she has to have her career and family
order
pretty much by the time she's 35
because otherwise the options start to
run out and so that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on women especially at
the end of their 20s i think i take
issue with the idea
that's a fact that's a it's a fact
he's spitting facts because
um 28 is right around the corner for me
and i'm like
at this point i want to email you
in the marriage i have mostly male
viewers if there's any cute guys in
london she's looking for money that's
the money gotta have money in a career
now
no he's it's it's not like a comfortable
truth but it's real right yeah it sucks
i'm like dang like why can't we be like
lenient with our lives kind of well
because a guy can have a kid at 50. yeah
us it's like if you hit 40 you're
pushing your love yeah what i wonder why
that is and that's going to be a tangent
but i just i've always wondered like how
come
our our reproductive system
like slows down or like just gets worse
as we get older
and the males they swimmers swim 24 7.
it's just biology it's just like life
isn't fair yeah
ah
but
well i like it
[Music]
because you know all women are different
and that's what i want to just put
another quote to you from the book
different in some ways and the same in
others
okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children and
you talk to one of your youtuber
interviews about crazy happy
so
simple question
is gender equality a myth in your view
is that something that's just never
going to happen
it depends on what you mean by equality
getting the same opportunities
fairly people we could get to a point
where people were treated fairly or more
fairly i mean people are treated pretty
fairly in western culture already but we
can they're really not though are they i
mean otherwise why would there only be
seven women running foot 100 companies
in the uk why why would there still be a
pay gap which we've discussed
why are women at the bbc saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same job that's not fair
let's go to the first question they're
both complicated questions seven seven
women repeat that one there's seven
women running the top ftse 100 companies
in the uk well
the first question might be um why would
you want to do that
why would a man want to do it
well there's a lot of money
there's a certain number of of men
although not that many
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life
to the pursuit of a high-end career so
they'll work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 48 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the top so you're
saying women are just more sensible they
don't want that because it's not an
isolation i'm saying that's part of it
definitely and so i work
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the top there are some barriers yeah
like other like men for example i mean
to get to the top of any organization is
an incredibly competitive enterprise and
the men that you're competing with are
simply not going to roll over and say
please take the position
absolutely all-out warfare is gender
equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia by that equality
of outcome is undesirable what men and
women what i was going to say let him
explain it
but
something that
he just said got me thinking
because
as a women we're not we're not taught
like oh
go like work hard at this one thing and
like there are some women that are
taught that but most women aren't taught
go work hard at this one thing excel at
this one thing so once you reach the the
top you can be at the top and stay at
the top and go past all these people
there's more so
men that are taught that because women
children be a mother you say at home mom
do this like live live your 20s and your
teens and half your 30s
uh doing you but once you get to that
point you know you're gonna have to find
somebody and get married and start
having kids so it's like it's not
programmed in us to want to
be
top of a big corporation or be a ceo or
this that in the third unless someone
has said like you know if that's
something you want to do or like have an
idea like go do it it's more so
men that have been taught that and
that's why
it's so heavily ran by males
do you think it's that they're taught or
that they want to
because in my experience like i feel
like from a young age i've been told i
could do anything and i feel like
feminism doesn't really like i feel like
feminism is really big in the u.s yes i
don't think they really push women to be
mothers
i think they push women to be more
career oriented
and from what i've seen like
i just think it's more like women who
wants to work 80 hours a week my dad did
that i don't want to do that no
and like he was saying men men are
more willing to do that
no
no could it be me it could not be me and
so i understand why i understand why um
there is like
more men running certain things because
they're more willing to sacrifice their
lives their body everything to be
at the top
and
women will sacrifice but there comes a
point where it's just like what about me
yeah i've been sacrificing so much what
about me and so
yeah
he's making some good points here he's
this man mr jordan this one you're gonna
hear me a lot of the times when i quote
stats they're from him okay you're gonna
hear him say a lot of stuff that i've
said like
i i love him he convinced me to stop
drinking he convinced me yeah like he i
love jordan peterson is my dude
i know the red pill has mixed feelings
about him because of his daughter but
that's you can't help how your
your kids turn out completely okay yeah
trust me you can't okay okay themselves
into the same categories if you leave
them alone to do it off their own accord
i've already seen that in scandinavia
it's 20 to one female nurses to male
something like that it might not be
quite that extreme and approximately the
same male engineers to female engineers
and that's a consequence of the free
choice of men and women in the societies
that have gone farther than any other
societies to make gender equality the
purpose of the law those are inerratical
differences you can eradicate them with
tremendous social pressure and tyranny
but if you leave men and women to make
their own choices you will not get equal
outcomes right so you're saying that
anyone who believes in equality whether
you call them feminists call them
whatever you want to call them should
basically give up because it ain't gonna
happen only if they're aiming at
equality of outcome
so you're saying give people equality of
opportunity that's fine not only fine
it's eminently desirable for everyone
for individuals and for society but
still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really it depends on
your measurement techniques they're
doing just fine in medicine
in fact there are far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians
there are lots of lots of disciplines
that are absolutely dominated by women
many many disciplines and they're doing
great
so let me put something else to you from
the book you say that's something that
what he just said you had uh
mentioned that in one of the podcasts
that there are
there are certain areas where women are
dominating and so it got me thinking
like when people
talk about
uh the gender pay cat pay gap and like
equality in the workplace
what
companies are
they talking about or what like area are
they talking about because if you look
at
say if you look at um cosmetics
that's all that's all women and men have
just
i will say in the last 10 years have
been like welcomed into that space
i don't know the pay for that area but
that's something that has been dominated
by women and now men are welcomed in
we're modeling like you don't see men
marching the streets demanding demanding
they get paid like kendall jenner yeah
yeah there's just
and i wonder if like men think about
that in the areas where like women
dominate and not just in like the
cosmetic or
modeling industry but i wonder in like
other areas where women dominate are
they like i want to be i want to be paid
just as much as my female counterpart is
that something that they think about or
they're just like oh
i'm here i'm working i'm getting paid it
don't matter
i don't think men are conditioned to
think like that but i think women are
because we're just told from such a
young age like there's this like pay gap
and like we're a prep yeah we are and
men aren't like they don't complain you
don't ever hear about like male suicide
rates like being higher than women or
like
male like males you know taking the
majority of hard jobs yeah that is true
like
i feel like
from just like small we're taught just
like
oh as a woman as a woman
this is going to be harder for you
because you're a woman this is going to
be different for you because you're a
woman instead of like
teaching us like okay yes this may be
different but this is how you can
get yourself to that position to where
you're you can put up a fight and be
like okay so
this man does this this and this i do
the same thing why aren't i like why
aren't i considered equal and that's
when you can have that conversation when
they if they if they let you have it
when it's like okay why and if they say
well
i don't know then you know
nine times out of ten it's because
you're a woman and he's a man
wait wait what no like so you're saying
nine times out of ten i misunderstood no
no so if
from
my understanding or what i would think
if you can do x y and z the same as
a man right you have the same
qualifications but they're getting paid
more i would say nine times out of ten
the reason why you're not
is
maybe because you're a woman or there
may be other like he was saying other
people
no that's right but see like to me my
mind now but it used to always jump to
like it's because she's a woman and
because she's a man but now like my mind
jumps to like well what else could it be
yeah because like i just don't know i
know a lot of people that hire people
and i there's no one i can like
point to and say you're sexist you would
dream yeah different like most of them
think money is green and they're like if
they could hire women at a cheaper rate
i think
yes they would and i know for uh
me when i
i don't think about this all the time
but there's sometimes where i think
about when i go into interview
i like if they look at my resume they're
gonna be like oh
jessica i'm like okay cool jessica they
don't know whether
what what i could be and then when i
walk in they're like oh
like she's black i always wonder like
does that play a factor because i'm a
woman and i'm black i get a double
whammy and i'm like um i don't know if
that has ever played a factor in any of
the job opportunities that i've had but
that's also like he was saying um
like
being a woman isn't the only factor
there's other factors that play into
just
pay gap and just the workforce in
general you know what's funny people
think i'm black before i get there
pearl i don't know why because pearl is
like davis
yeah it's davis pearl pearl davis that
sounds like a old southern i've got me
miss pearl miss pearly i show up i'm
like hey guys
oh
not what i thought
cause i worked in sales too and it would
be the same like
okay and over the phone you can't tell
because there's some there's some black
women that i have a friend who talks
very
um
what's not i guess you say proper very
proper
and um
she sounds like over the phone she
sounds like she could be a
blue eyed blonde hair white girl but
when you see her in person you're like
oh you're black
so i can understand that
okay the introduction of the equal pay
for equal work argument immediately
complicates even salary comparison
beyond practicality for one simple
reason who decides what work is equal
it's not possible so the simple question
is do you believe in equal pay
[Music]
he's answered this so many times kathy
yeah
oh i made the argument there so it
depends
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
doctor you're actually not listening
i'm just being pretty definitely and i'm
hearing you
say are you listening very carefully
because are you kathy you have asked him
things like oh so you don't believe in
he's like i never said that oh so would
you celebrate that why why wouldn't he i
don't think you're listening to me i
don't i don't think she's listening at
all she wants to get her
her questions out and her point that's
that's a sign when someone when someone
says something and you react in a way
that is not connected to what they said
that means you are not listening to them
you're trying to just get out what you
want to say before you even think about
responding to what they said yeah no
exactly
saying women need to just accept they're
never going to make it on equal terms
equal outcomes is what how you defined
it no idea if i was a young woman
watching that i would go well i might as
well just go and play with my cindy
dolls i'd give up trying at school
because i'm not going to get the top job
i want because there's someone sitting
there saying it's not possible it's
horrible
desirable that's what i said it's a bad
social goal i didn't say that women
shouldn't be striving for the top or
anything like that because i don't
believe that for a second striving for
the top but you're gonna put all those
hurdles in their way as has been in
their way for centuries and that's fine
you're saying that's fine no no i think
i really the patriarchal system is just
silly i do i think that's silly i really
do i mean look look at your situation
you're hardly unsuccessful yeah and i
asked how do you very hard to get
exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is all about inevitable but you talk
about men fighting let me just put
another thing to you from the bottom
you're saying
for a high quality position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote and underlying threat
of physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversations
between women is that something all are
we sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you
well you just said that i fought to get
where i've got yeah what does that mean
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing success
for women i'm not very agreeable right
i've noticed that actually confrontation
at least and i'm sure it served your
career well successful women though
basically have to wear the trousers in
your view they have to sort of become
men to succeed is what you're saying
well if they're i've had to fight to
succeed
[Music]
in a society like in a society that is
geared
around men it's kind of like
you have to
what is that saying um
if you can't be in a if you can't beat
them join them in a sense you're gonna
have to
you're gonna have to do things that men
have to do it sucks and it's like it's
just it's just a reality of it until
things change to where it's like i can
just be me and do me and be
to
like strive to get to the top and not
have these hurdles that are just there
then
it's
you're gonna have to do what you you're
gonna have to do what you need to do to
get to the top
well and then there's a double-edged
whammy right because you become so like
to become successful you got to become
more masculine basically like
disagreeable right because that's
associated with leadership and the
reason is like someone that's agreeable
like i'm very agreeable okay and that's
like why
like if i was to fire somebody okay i
would have a really hard time doing that
yeah but like someone that's
disagreeable doesn't they make decisions
quick like that's why like you know
trump fired everybody mm-hmm
makes quick decisions good leader right
i mean
you know some people will say yeah yeah
yeah but you understand like that
mentality but so then you become more um
masculine right but then you have
problems in dating
because men don't want masculine women
yeah
you know what so it's like a
double-edged sword that's why you see
all these successful women and they
don't have
[Music]
i always wondered that like why you
would think that like oh she's
successful she has a man this life is
made but it comes back to the point you
just made and if they are have you ever
noticed they're a little bit more like
feminine if they are like if the if it's
like a super masculine dominant like
usually the guy is kind of feminine yeah
they're more so
like she or i think it was she said like
the woman wears the trousers in the
family and he was saying like no woman
wants a
uh like a non-um dominant man and i'm
like
you got a point there right there
spitting facts jordan okay certainly
masculine traits are going to be helpful
i mean one of the things i do in in my
counseling practice for example when i'm
consulting with women who are trying to
advance their careers is to teach them
how to negotiate and to and to be able
to say no and to not be easily pushed
around and to be formidable and you need
to if you're going to be successful you
need to be smart conscientious and tough
well here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay raises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay
well i would say partly because it's not
so easy to determine what constitutes
the same job but almost because
arguably
there are still men dominating our
industries our society and therefore
they've dictated the terms for so long
that women have to battle to know that's
not true
it's not true so for example
well i can give you an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the law firms didn't
use these masculine criteria then
perhaps women would do better but the
market sets the damn game it's like and
the market is dominated by manchester
united it's not the market is dominated
by women they make eighty percent of the
consumer decisions that's not the case
at all if you're talking about people
who stay at home looking after children
by and large they are still women so
they're going out doing the shopping but
that is changing they make all these
things
okay so what a market is driven by women
not men right okay and if you're a
lawyer they still pay more for the same
so if it's
she was saying or
um yes she was saying that the consumer
rate is
um
mostly women staying at home blah blah
blah she was saying it's changing
so since that changing
wouldn't you think that
the
the way things are ran are like
similarly going in that like direction
as well or do you think that if like the
if men jumped up to be more the
consumers that it would just stay the
same
um well i think
so are you saying like that women you
think because women buy more stuff like
that we'll see more women and ceo and
like power positions is that what you're
asking
no so i'm saying that if it
if it changes to where
men are the top consumers will
the
workforce change like how it's flopped
so like right now men are dominating and
women are the top consumers if men
become the top consumers would it be
like on the flip side that women start
dominating
i don't think so because i i really
think it's just the personality trait
disagreeableness yeah because i can
think of every team i've been on every
captain has been a little bit of a like
a [ __ ] to be honest like for the most
part but it makes them a better leader
yeah and it's a reason like i think i've
like haven't been chosen for captain
positions i'm i'm pretty agreeable i
don't take charge of a situation i think
men are just more like that
but oh my god if men you know what's
crazy women
like have so much debt
like women because we make less we spend
more
like and i just think our whole society
is like geared towards women and once
you see it you can't unsee it like
everything like that's why they're
getting these plus-sized people in the
media it's for women
that is true that because like men like
that men
yeah because i feel like and we've
talked about this on one of the pre-game
shows yeah i feel like
men don't there's a lot of stuff that
women care about that men could just
care less about and the stuff that
they can care less about women care
about more so it's like oh let's gear
that towards them
and
then it just
there's just more things i feel like
women care more about to like consume or
to buy than men do yeah
yeah
sort of goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet it's going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
that's true if you flop if you switch
that price they'd be like um excuse me
why is why is the blue helmet
more than the pink one like they're both
same helmets say brand same everything
that is true because there will be some
things i see in the store and i'm like
why is this like this i'm like you know
it's the price i'll just go pay for it
it's what it is
yeah no i agree i agree is it not
desirable to have some of those female
traits you're talking about i'd say
that's a generalization but you've used
the words female traits is it not
desirable to have some of them at the
top of business i mean maybe there
wouldn't be they don't predict the
banking crisis they don't predict
success in the workplace the things that
predict success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these topics
[Music]
yeah killing me
like she's putting words in his mouth
yeah they say so they're not
those words ever come out of his mouth
but i can
it's it's weird but i like and
understand like what he's saying like if
i'm the top ceo of a company
and
someone is disagreeing with me and i
needed something they're like well i
can't do it like well okay just like get
it done on your own time knowing that i
have a deadline but um oh it's okay it's
okay and like there's times where i've
done that and i'm like dang
i wonder i wonder why women
like can't be like that in the workforce
and then be able to like separate it
from when they like go into
other realms of their life
so watching this would you say you're
more agreeable or disagreeable i would
say i'm more agreeable with what he has
so do you think when you go to
basketball you can magically become a
disagreeable person
more than like there's the difference
between slightly and a complete
personality change
because i've played with you you're
pretty nice to play with i like playing
like i like but you don't you don't yell
at anyone you don't like yeah i get
intense but i don't know
like you can't just change who you are
as a person but it's not a bad thing
like it's gonna make you like a better
mother and a better like like women i
just think we're naturally nurturing
yeah and we value relationships more
than men do yeah and i don't i don't
think it's a bad thing like i think it's
our super power like to be able to like
connect with people yeah but
like it just comes at a co everything
comes at a cost
today wow she's getting red pilled on
camera on camera oh look at me
female traits don't predict success but
i didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
one female church is by implication are
not female traits oh no i mean
if we were going based on intelligence
statistically
women
are
more intelligent than men if that was if
that was what she's trying to say
we if we were going based on that and
the work fit in the workforce and
everything
women would be at the top of the game
sort of no i'm saying like based on like
what she's saying no no do you know what
like how intelligence is distributed so
there's more women in the middle and
there's more men on the extremes
so there's more men that are like idiots
and there's more men's that are geniuses
but women are like more in the middle
okay
i think guys you can let me know in the
comments i'm like 80 sure that's right i
swear
so that's what like
no i've just been like doing this do you
know what i'm saying like i can't expect
you to know this yeah you're you're a
normal person
i'm a blue pillar
but um
but then like you take into
conscientiousness too so it's like
yeah like the stuff he's saying is very
like it gets you thinking because if you
don't know you're going to
either be
on
his side of the spectrum and not change
not want to hear nobody else or going to
be on her side of the spectrum and not
want to hear yeah
i'm right in the middle yeah
no this is this is what i actually
picked you because i was like oh she's
blue pill but she could listen so like
let's see how she died that's very much
interesting i'm not saying that at all
are women less intelligent than men no
no no they're not no they did that on
that's pretty clear the average iq for a
woman in the average iq for a man is
identical there is some debate about the
flatness of the distribution which is
something that james pointed out for
example in his memo but there's no
difference at all in general cognitive
ability there's no difference to speak
of in conscientiousness women are a bit
more orderly than men and men are a
little bit more industrious than women
but the difference isn't big i don't
think that averages into any men who
aren't necessarily well of course
why are they not feminine why are they
not desirable at the top of feminine
traits why are they not desirable it's
hard to say i'm just laying out the
empirical evidence like we know that we
know the traits that predict success but
we also know because companies by and
large have not been dominated by women
over the centuries we have nothing to
compare it to
it's an experiment
true and it could be the case that if
companies modified their behavior and
became more feminine they would be
successful but there's no evidence for
it i'm not neither doubtful nor
non-doubtful there's no evidence why not
give it a go as the
are you deaf ma'am
why not give it a go like
you give it a go you try it that's what
makes me mad is this man actually is
working to help women yeah and he's
actually out there like you know what
irritates me people doing nothing
criticizing people doing doing something
yeah so like she's out here criticizing
him but man what are you you just have a
talk show yeah you say you're a feminist
i know nothing about this lady but you
say you're a feminist what are you doing
to
help out
women like what are you doing to further
what you are talking about today like
what's your area in that yeah
and he's out here doing the work yeah
she's coming at him like this is who you
should this is why like sometimes guys
feminists
y'all don't even help people that are
trying to help you
yeah
he's on your side exactly
i wonder why
feminists are so
i won't say against because i don't i
know nothing about
nothing when it comes to being a
feminist or whatnot but from what i've
seen when
a male tries to step in and help
or like talk to them about
uh just a female community and women in
general
why is it like no we don't need your
help and it's like but you kind of
do because they're
it's their it's their world kind of and
you want somebody that is
essentially the world benefits from them
so they can help you
know how to navigate and create a world
that's beneficial for you yeah i'm like
speak for yourself i could you i i have
a coat rack guys
anybody know how to build a coat rack
live in london
miss pearl needs some help
okay we're almost done
well it's fine like if someone wants to
start a company and make it more
feminine and compassionate let's say and
caring in its overall orientation
towards its workers and towards the
marketplace then that's a perfectly
reasonable experiment to run my point is
that there is no evidence that those
traits predict success in the workplace
and there's
evidence
well that's not that's not really the
case women have been in the workplace
for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fair fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries
i wonder who posted this
this was man of all creation
okay i was wondering if this was like
the actual
so what do you what do you think of
jordan peterson i like him because it
like i said in the beginning it doesn't
sound like he's just going off at the
mouth but he has like real like
stats and real like psychological points
behind it to where
it's
it's understandable what he is saying
um something that
came to mind at the end and he kind of
said it
since
women
have to learn the traits
of
success in certain fields why
it's like why don't women
create in so let me get my thoughts
together so there are
there are women dominated areas it's
like why
don't
if you can create you can create a
business that
is more
feminine like and women will will
succeed in that because that's the
that's just something that comes natura
to us now when you go into an area that
is not natural to you you're going to
have to learn some things and so that's
why
women
aren't succeeding in those areas because
like he was saying because they don't
because they don't have those traits yet
then they have to learn them and because
men naturally have those traits so
they're naturally going to succeed in
those areas i feel like from what he was
saying um i don't agree with him saying
that um
the
the um
excuse me the female traits
are
are not successful or like they have
been deemed as not successful i think
that
you can there can be a female that
starts a business and like she
is not agreeable and whatnot and has the
female traits that he was talking about
and be successful i think that but if
she enters a realm that is
more so uh
ran by
man males i don't think that well i
think it depends on
the industry and that's what he was
talking about like nursing women it's
like women excel in places of people
because agreeableness people like you
better
people don't like the [ __ ] the captain
[ __ ] on the team people like her not at
all no but they listen to it yeah right
and it's like they're they're at odds so
in industries with people women excel
yeah but it's just like when it comes to
salary negotiation who's going to get
paid more the [ __ ] captain on the team
or or me it's obviously her yeah because
she's gonna get things done essentially
or they know like she's gonna say no
yeah yeah and she's gonna
then she's just gonna have more
more traits that
are geared not geared but more traits of
a
male than a female if yeah in that sense
so i i liked i like jordan mr jordan it
was good do you feel like you're
starting to get red pelt is this going
to make you see life a little different
i don't know i
even in like the
the um pregame show that i've been on
i've like just thought differently and
thought about things differently so this
is the red pill before gears are turning
guys
this was me like a year and a half ago
like six months
she's gonna
look at the world
i'm not ready i'm so excited okay guys
let us know in the comments how you guys
like this show um next week jess is
gonna host her own show so i won't even
be here i'll be behind the camera oh boy
um
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell like the
video ellie shut up oh my god like the
video okay do not forget to like this
video and let us know in the comments
what videos would red pill her next i'm
down for anything i'm scared bye guys